dal video non sembrerebbe ma vi posso
garantire che
non sono un pazzo
e ho un sacco di paura Sì perché per
superare i limiti
Io penso che bisogna rendere la paura
un'amica e per me è la mia migliore
amica cerco di spiegarmi meglio che un
esempio avete ora visto tutti il video
dove volo dentro le due gallerie nessuno
mai prima aveva provato a fare una cosa
del genere quindi non avevo niente a cui
appigliarmi non avevo nessuna a cui
chiedere consiglio
Però avevo due vie esattamente come le
due gallerie la prima via Per riuscire
in questa impresa
era essere impavido come spesso ci
dicono purtroppo secondo me non avere
paura la paura è il tuo limite
senza paura
raggiungerai quello che vuoi
la seconda via
era invece quella che io chiamo del
fifone Ascolta le tue paure fidati delle
tue paure rendi le tue paure le tue
migliori amiche Beh Come avrete
immaginato già da prima quando ho
iniziato e Come avrete capito Io ho
scelto la via del fifone
Sì perché
non potevo rischiare
un progetto del genere deve essere fatto
alla perfezione se si è impavidi se si
sovrarvaluta sopravvaluta se stessi si
rischia tutto si rischia di rendere un
sogno che io da quando avevo 12 anni e
che ho coltivato per 29 anni un incubo
un incubo senza Uscita mentre invece
quelle due gallerie avevano due uscite e
dovevo centrarle entrambe al primo colpo
alla perfezione adotte 300 km all'ora
quindi c'era solo un modo per me
ascoltare le mie paure però la seconda
via aveva un problema la seconda via
voleva dire avere per 14 mesi
notti in bianco svegliarsi con un incubo
con delle paure che io ho deciso di
annotare su un quaderno quindi per 14
mesi Io mi sono svegliato ogni notte e
ho segnato su un quadernino la paura e
poi quella paura è diventata il mio
compito a casa Non ho fatto altro che
per ogni paura trovare una soluzione
insieme Ovviamente all'aiuto di un team
pazzesco
questo glielo chiamo a fare i compiti a
casa esattamente come ci si prepara per
un esame Tutti quanti abbiamo fatto
esami a scuola e tutti quanti abbiamo
una paura tremenda dell'esame Ma se ci
pensiamo un pochino meglio non abbiamo
paura dell'esame Non abbiamo paura di
essere qui e parlare con voi abbiamo
paura di essere qui e fallire abbiamo
paura di non superare l'esame eppure le
risposte a tutte quelle domande che ci
aspettano All'esame sono lì nei libri
nelle lezioni negli appunti quindi cosa
dobbiamo fare Dobbiamo semplicemente
ascoltare la paura a dire la paura ci
dice che non possiamo rispondere a
quella domanda non possiamo fallire
quella domanda Allora niente Dobbiamo
semplicemente fare i compiti a casa
studiare rimboccarci le maniche avere un
po' di disciplina selfie stippling
cercare di fare i compiti a casa ed è il
concetto che io applico ad ogni singolo
volo che faccio i compiti a casa Non
faccio altro che pensare a quali sono i
rischi di quel volo
vado faccio i compiti a casa perché
quelle paure signori miei sono basate
sulla nostra esperienza e sulle nostre
conoscenze sui nostri studi niente altro
Quindi se quei compiti a casa vengono
fatti alla perfezione o quasi Quando
inizia l'azione stessa la paura smetti
di tormentarci e si entra in quello che
si chiama lo stato mentale Del Flow in
the zone ed è quello che è successo a me
in quelle gallerie quando ho chiuso il
Canopi il tettuccio acceso il motore
tutte le paure il cuore che batteva a
mille si è calmato e sono entrato nel
mio Flow e da quel momento per 60
secondi non mi sono più ricordato nulla
non ho visto nulla Sono andato come un
robot come una freccia dritta
l'obiettivo senza essere disturbata dei
44 secondi all'interno del tunnel mi
ricordo solo tre secondi purtroppo per
fortuna c'erano 100 telecamere che
riprendevano quindi mi sono goduto lo
spettacolo dopo però perché 60 secondi
di Flow perché io mi sono allenato per
14 mesi 560 secondi esattamente come
fanno i calciatori per una partita la
partita dura un'ora e mezza bene Noi
dobbiamo prepararci per due ore per
essere al 100% per un'ora e mezza e lo
stesso ho fatto io mi sono visualizzato
e preparato per 60 secondi se vedete il
video Io inizio esultare esattamente 60
secondi dal decollo sembra una cosa
pazzesca non ci credevo nemmeno mi
chiedevo perché se 10 secondi in più era
il flow noi abbiamo sempre fatto tutta
la mia preparazione di allenamento di 60
secondi quindi Flow esiste è uno stato
mentale che esista
il mio tempo sta per scadere qui però
prima di lasciarvi Volevo farvi una
domanda è una domanda che io mi porto
dietro da sempre da quando sono bambino
Mia moglie mi dice che non è possibile
che non è vero che ho torto io invece ci
credo e voglio provare a farla a voi se
il talento non esistesse se il talento
come lo crediamo e pensiamo noi come ci
è stato spiegato dal vocabolario negli
ultimi decenni non esistesse Se non
esistesse un talento naturale se noi
potessimo veramente realizzare quello
che vogliamo e se il talento in realtà
fosse come dice Dante Nella Divina
Commedia la passione quella cosa che non
riusciamo a toglierci di mente quella
cosa che non riusciamo a smettere di
sognare o se fosse come ha detto
Einstein che non aveva talento lui aveva
solamente un sacco un sacco di passione
e ha studiato ma soprattutto aveva
tantissima autocritica o se il talento
di Leonardo Da Vinci Anzi mille Talenti
erano amici che il mio idolo non fossero
Talenti Ma fossero semplicemente frutto
di quello che era la sua incredibile
curiosità e dei quasi 5000 libri che
aveva nella sua biblioteca Da quanto era
appassionato a studiare a conoscere la
più grande biblioteca o libreria
dell'epoca se queste persone hanno
ragione se io quelle due gallerie non le
ho superate grazie a un talento che per
non so quale natura o quale scienza sono
un qualcosa con il quale io sono nato
Pensateci un attimo se quelli due
gallerie io le passate semplicemente
perché ho ascoltato le mie paure quelle
di mia moglie quelle di mio figlio
quelli miei amici e quelle dei 40 per su
quelle per 40 persone del team che mi
hanno supportato e che ogni giorno
mettevamo sul tavolo dicevamo bene
Questa è la lista che dobbiamo mitigare
oggi e se fosse per questo motivo che io
sono riuscito in questa impresa e non
perché sono nato fenomeno
vi lascio con questo dubbio Grazie
[Applauso]